so a vertical guideline is basically you
can think of it as a new edge of the
screen so it's like I have one on the
left of the screen I have one on the
right screen and now I've put an edge of
the screen in the middle of the screen
that I can use as an anchor for
constraints I'm gonna head and move that
to where I'd like it in my design and
now I can just take those text views and
create constraints from those two this
guideline and to kind of visualize what
this is doing underneath if I move the
guideline it's actually gonna move the
entire layout now so we could go into
helpers and we use add vertical barrier
this allows you to add a barrier to the
screen what a barrier is is it's kind of
like a view through the text it's
actually called a grouping code so we
can open up the component tree select
our email and password and drag that
down to be inside of our barrier now
it's not actually a view group it's just
a view that's added to the screen it's
positioned on one side or the other of
all of the views that are inside of it
right by default it's on the left but if
I open up the attributes pain and scroll
down to the bottom I'm going to find a
barrier direction which I can set to the
end and now that I've done that I'm
gonna set up my constraints and then
translate my English over to German and
everything's gonna relay out and do
exactly what I expected we've added the
ability to add constraints directly with
the context menu so in this case you
know if you have components that are
really close to each other this makes it
a lot more precise and more direct to
actually set those constraints so in
this case and this is available in 3 3
beta as well so you can try it out today
and so in this case if we select one
component which we have this lovely cat
picture you can just simply constrain it
to the parent so what does it look like
if you have multiple multiple components
so in this case we have these two text
views that are really close to each
other and so not sure if people have
tried to create constraints between two
text views that almost overlap it
becomes a little painful when you're
going from the bottom of one to the top
of the other and so with this new
context menu you can actually just keep
the two selected
and then when you open them the context
menu there's now this constrained menu
and so you can actually just see that
the two elements that you want to use
are there and then you can easily
cascade to the right constraint that you
want the design surface has always had a
bunch of view options to me to take
advantage of when you're working with
your layouts so the two I'll talk about
specifically are which we added is show
all constraints and live rendering what
we've done in Android studio 3.3 is
we've added this option to show all
constraints but it's actually turned off
by default and so here's a quick video
to show you what that looks like
and so what we'll do instead is we only
show the constraints on the actively
selected component so this makes it
easier to just you know work with the
component that you're actually working
with and not be distracted by all the
arrows and margins that usually come
with the layout the other view option we
have is live rendering so we've actually
done live rendering by default in
constraint layout for quite some time
and so it's on by default but depending
on the specs of your machine and act it
can actually be a little slow you've
actually been able to zoom in pan in the
layout editor for a while now and it
comes really in handy when you're
dealing with constraint layouts
especially when again when things are
really small or when they're really
close to each other overlapping but what
we've done in 3/3 is we've actually
changed the keyboard shortcuts to match
more of what we expect from the design
tools like Photoshop and sketch and so
to zoom in you can use command or
control depending on what OS you're on
and then the equals sign and then with
the mouse wheel you can use you can hold
command or control and scroll up and
then if you have a trackpad you can just
pinch into zoom then the opposite is for
zoom out so it's command and control -
and then command and control with the
mouse wheel scroll down and then pinch
in the opposite direction and then zoom
to fit so if you're zoomed in and you
want to get back to that layout where
you can see the whole thing you can just
use command and control + 0 and so then
if you're zoomed in and you don't
actually want to zoom out but you want
to pan around you can actually do so by
holding space and then using the mouse
to kind of click and drag
[Music]